Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Worüber wollen wir reden?
Wir sagen erst, was wir im Salon lesen.
Oh, warte, wir müssen erst sagen, dieser Podcast heute ist wieder pünktlich bei Spotify.
Ah ja.
Und der letzte war leider verspätet bei Spotify, weil die amerikanischen Tech-Pros, die auf Europa Einfluss haben, nicht wollten, dass unseren Zykligalbesprechung in der Welt, nein. Es gibt Umstellung, technische Umstellung. Das kann man ja mal kurz erklären für Leute, die es interessiert. Typischerweise ist ja Podcast ein RSS-Medium. Das heißt, ein über zwei Jahrzehnte altes Format proliferiert den Podcast in die Welt. Und das ist eigentlich gut, das ist ein offenes Standards. Jetzt haben aber unser Hoster und Spotify umgestellt auf irgendeinen API-technischen Zugang, keine Ahnung. Weil ja alles Video wird jetzt. Selbst Apple Podcasts überall ist jetzt dieses Video zu sehen. Und dabei kommt es natürlicherweise zu Fehler. Ohne, dass diese Techie-Leute, die jetzt alles mit Kot zusammenklamüsern, noch mal daran denken, dass sie auch Fehlermeldungen mitliefern sollten. Also im Sinne von kam nicht bei Spotify an, warum, ja keine Ahnung. Und dann habe ich ein bisschen investigiert und habe sehr viel schneller herausgefunden als unser Hoster, dass es an der Länge der Show Notes liegt. Also wir haben einfach die 10.000 Zeichenmarke durchbrochen. Ich denke mir, ja, ich hätte gerne die Freiheit, Leuten, die vielleicht noch mal nachlesen wollen, worüber wir sprechen, sozusagen den Prompt abzunehmen, dass wir einfach selber kurz zusammenfassen, warum es in Kapiteln geht. Aber das ist uns jetzt ein bisschen, also klar, 10.000 ist eine hohe Marke. Da kann man immer ein bisschen was schreiben, ja. So, genau. Außerdem der Hinweis, die Show Notes beim letzten Mal, waren wirklich ganz schnell so mit veröffentlicht. Die habe ich ja im Nachhinein noch mal schön gemacht. Ja, deswegen ist leider, also wenn ihr das hier bei Spotify hört, ja, Wolfgang und ich, wir haben zwei Stunden über den Enzyklika des Papstes gesprochen. Es könnte noch an euch vorbeigegangen sein. Denn bei Spotify wird ja dann ein 5-Tage-Alter-Podcast veröffentlicht, der nicht gleich ganz oben angezeigt wird. Da wir noch sehr häufig auf die Enzyklika zurückkommen, wie heute zum Beispiel auch, lohnt sich das vielleicht, das sich noch mal anzuhören.
Das sowieso, man hat auch eine höhere Sicherheit, wenn man uns abonniert hat, wenn man hinter die Bezahlschranke tritt, dass man immer alles mitbekommt. Das ist möglich über Steady, Apple oder Patreon. Steady empfehlen wir ja besonders. Und wir sprechen diese Folge, also im Salon, nachdem wir jetzt ein bisschen Vorgeplänkel machen und auf Wolfgang Kubicki eingehen, sprechen wir danach dann hinter der Paywall sehr ausführlich über Bücher, die neu erschienen sind. Wir sprechen über Gegenmacht, die Zivilgesellschaft schlägt zurück, das neue Buch von Arne Semshott. Wir hatten schon sein erstes Buch besprochen, dies ist sein neues. Er zeigt also jetzt auf, was kann eigentlich zivilgesellschaftlich erfolgen gegen Rechtsruck und so weiter. Außerdem beschäftigen wir uns mit dem Thema Kunstfreiheit. Und ich muss es gleich spezifizieren. Wie ist es mit staatlich geförderter Kunst, beziehungsweise Kunst, die in staatlichen Institutionen stattfindet? Welchen Einfluss darf der Staat darauf nehmen, auf das, was da ausgestellt wird, auf die Personen, die da ausstellen oder etwas performen oder lesen, was auch immer. Das ist ein Buch von Christoph Möllers und Nils Weinberg, Öffentliche Kunstfreiheit. Ursprünglich ein Gutachten, das dann erweitert wurde. Keine leichte Lektüre, aber für uns doch sehr erhellend, dass wir das einmal uns klar machen können, wo liegen eigentlich die Unterschiede und was ist zu beachten. Und ja, es sind so ein paar kleine Empfehlungen, liegen da auch drin. Wir werden sehen, was für uns daraus folgt als Debatte.
Nicht nur ein Gutachten von Möllers, der dann den Weinberg fragte, ob man den Text mal in gemeinsamer Arbeit noch obskurer machen könnte, also selten so dicht, sondern dieser Text versteckt sich ja auch hinter einer Gutachtensprache, um noch mal klar zu machen, wie das Verhältnis aus Kunstfreiheit und antisemitischer Kunst ist. Wenn man sie als solche erkennt, darf dann gleich der Schulleiter in die Aula rennen und sagen, nicht in meinem Haus oder etwa nicht und so. Also das ist sozusagen doppelt obskur.
Ja, aber im guten Sinne, denn wir werden tatsächlich eine Klarheit gewinnen in diesen Debatten und sind dann gerüstet für die Debatten, die noch kommen werden, denn wir können sicher sein, eine Politisierung findet statt überall. Das heißt, diese Debatten werden zunehmen und da gibt es auch so die ein oder andere Nebensätze, die ordentlich reinhauen. Dann habe ich dabei ein Buch, das sich mit Marmor, Quecksilber, Nebel beschäftigt, woraus die Welt gemacht ist. Heißt der Untertitel von Judith Schalansky. Ich spreche mit der Autorin auf der Lit Kolon am Sonntag, also am siebten und habe dieses Buch jetzt gelesen. Ich bin sehr begeistert von diesen literarischen Essays. Außerdem habe ich einen sehr ungewöhnlichen, sehr guten Roman gelesen, was nicht gesagt werden kann, von David Schalai. Er ist ein Autor, der eine Prosa des Minimalismus schreibt, weil das zu den Protagonisten passt. Wir haben einen Mann, Istvan, der am liebsten gar nicht spricht oder wenn er spricht, dann sagt er okay oder ja oder okay. Wie geht man so durchs Leben? Und so erleben wir, wie jemand durch Unfälle und Zufälle aufsteigt in die Upper Class von London und auch wieder fällt. Und in diesem minimalistischen Stil ist das alles geschildert. Da ist nicht die große Inhaltlichkeit, aber da ist eine Inhaltlichkeit. Und manchmal zieht es einem wirklich den Boden weg beim Lesen. Ich bin sehr begeistert davon. Und außerdem gibt es einen Musiktipp. Ich habe mir auch noch angesehen, was Franziska Brandner, die Grünen-Vorsitzende, zum Thema Liberalismus zu sagen hat. Wir sprechen jetzt gleich über Liberalismus im Hinblick auf die FDP und was die Grünen da vorhaben. Nun ja.
Okay, gut. Ich ergänze heute auch unsere beiden Bücher durch ein drittes. Stefan Kühl, Führung und Gefolgschaft. Wir sprachen schon einige Male darüber. Diesmal müssen wir es uns vorstellen. Ich kann hier schon mal sagen, für alle, die immer wieder fragen, welches Buch soll ich denn lesen zum Einstieg in irgendetwas? Das ist wirklich das beste Soziologie-Lehrbuch der letzten Jahre. Außerdem, es gibt eine Firma, die heißt Avery, die macht Software und deren Chef hat einen Text darüber geschrieben, After Automation, wie es so ist in einer Firma, in der im Grunde alles automatisiert ist und seine E-Mails auch zu 95% nicht nur gelesen, sondern auch beantwortet werden in seinem Sinne von einer KI. Und der springt nun dem Papst bei. Allerdings 20 Tage bevor der Papst seine Enzyklika veröffentlicht hat, ist wirklich auf dem Punkt dieses große Diktum, das ist nur Datenverarbeitung, wird hier richtig bestätigt. Und ich denke, wir werden die nächsten Jahre einen großen Konflikt haben zwischen Leuten, die dem Papst-Lager angehören. Also ich rechne uns beiden jetzt aber auch dazu. Und diesen Avery-Typen. Und alternativ dazu zum einen Jeffrey Hinton, der schon sagt, die Dinger leben und so weiter. Das ist der große Google-Mastermind-Professor-Nobelpreis zu diesem Thema, der allerdings flankiert wird in Deutschland neuerdings von Markus Gabriel, der auch sagt, diese Dinger, ich weiß nicht genau, Gabriel sagt, die leben und so, aber er geht sehr in diese Richtung. Und von daher hauen wir heute eine weitere Kerbe in das Datenverarbeitung mit sehr guten Argumentationen aus einem Techniktagebuch sozusagen. Und am Ende Sebastian Hubers, der Begriff der Narrative in Hegemonie, also Charlie Kirk, ich hatte es ja angekündigt, wir gehen nochmal durch die Hausarbeit durch, durch die Bachelorarbeit durch.
Wunderbar. Jetzt zuvor aber haben wir mitbekommen, dass Deutschland doch keinen Sitz im UN-Sicherheitsrat erhalten wird. Wir können daran sehen, die Außenpolitik von Friedrich Merz und Vorgänger wird ordentlich abgestraft, vor allem auch die Außenpolitik in Bezug auf Gaza. Und jetzt auch natürlich das Duckmäusertum von Friedrich Merz gegenüber Donald Trump hat sich dann hier jetzt doch als schlecht herausgestellt, obwohl man ja der zweitgrößte Beitragszahler ist. Also hat man schon hier einen ordentlichen Affront kassiert. Und auch Baerbock ist ja international nicht gerade beliebt. Insofern rächt sich das jetzt alles, was so an Hybris in den letzten Jahren und bis in die Gegenwart zu beobachten ist.
Ja, wir koppeln das ja gleich mit oder du koppelst es mit hier Kubicki. Derzeit ist ja wirklich total schräg. Wir haben ja schon über den Sadismus geschrieben. Also dass die AfD nicht wie die NSDAP uns echt Wahlgeschenke macht, sondern uns die ganze Zeit quält. Und so einige Vorzeichen scheinen echt verdreht zu sein, denn Annalena Baerbock ist in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit nicht sehr beliebt. International, du hast gesagt, nicht sehr beliebt. Sie ist in den Apparaten auch nicht sehr beliebt, weil sie ja da die ganzen Leute ausgeholt hat und so. Die ist eigentlich nirgendwo beliebt. Und ich stelle mir wirklich die Frage, wenn die Demokratie wirklich so funktionieren sollte, wie es uns immer verkauft wird. Sie spült nur die Besten nach oben. Man hat eine echte Bewährungsprobe. Man muss schon so 40, 50 Millionen Leute von sich überzeugen. Und andauernd sehen wir Merz hier, Kubicki da, Annalena Baerbock da, Wadepool, bei dem wirklich der Scherz ist, für den Fall, dass er jetzt einfach geht. Dann geht er, wie er gekommen ist, aus heiterem Himmel. Niemand kennt ihn. Einfach so ein 60-jähriger Mann, der plötzlich auf der Bühne steht, ein bisschen Außenpolitik spielt, die ganze Zeit immer nur denselben Scheiß labert. Ja, wir stehen immer noch an deren Seite, die stehen immer noch an unserer Seite. Er spricht die ganze Zeit im Namen von irgendwem, aber wir wissen, der redet nicht mal mit den Leuten über dir da und für die er da angeblich spricht. Also wirklich aus heiterem Himmel kommt er so, ist irgendwie Außenminister, geht wieder weg. So eine Spurendlosigkeit, die dahinterlassen wird, ist wirklich sagenhaft. Also irgendwas ist mit dieser Demokratie wirklich ganz schief gerade.
Ich will aber Wolfgang Kubicki da ausnehmen aus dieser Reihe, die du jetzt gerade aufgetan hast und will jemand anderes in diese Reihe stellen, nämlich Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann. Wir haben das mitbekommen, es gab eigentlich die Alleinkandidatur von Wolfgang Kubicki, dann aber plötzlich ganz überraschend, eine einstündige Rede war auch schon vorbereitet oder nicht vorbereitet von Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann, dass sie jetzt als Gegenkandidatin antritt. Ich glaube, 45 Minuten. Sie hat lange geredet. Ich habe es mir nicht angehört, bin ja nicht verrückt. Allerdings interessant war ja, dass sie also da auftritt und sagt, ich bin jetzt die Gegenkandidatin, hat dann 40 Prozent der Stimmen, 60 Prozent der Stimmen bei Wolfgang Kubicki. Meine Einschätzung dieser Geschichte ist die folgende, dass sich Kubicki durchgesetzt hat, ist für die FDP gut. Also mich verbindet mit Wolfgang Kubicki wirklich nur der Vornahme. Seitdem er auch anfängt, dann doch nicht für Free Speech zu sein, sondern auch versucht Klagen zu führen gegen El Hotso oder so, ist er bei mir unten durch. Ich fand ihn vorher einfach auch immer noch lustig und dachte, naja gut, wenn er so redet, wie der Mund ihm gewachsen ist, gut. Aber wenn er dann andere versucht einzuhägen, dann finde ich das nicht mehr gut, kann das nicht mehr mittragen. Aber ich will jetzt gar nicht bewerten, wie ist Wolfgang Kubicki, was könnte der für mich bedeuten? Denn das spielt alles gar keine Rolle. Ich werde die FDP niemals wählen. Von daher brauche ich mich darum nicht zu kümmern. Ich will aber sagen, die Wahl für Kubicki ist gut für die FDP. Wenn die FDP eine Chance hat, dann nur mit jemanden wie Wolfgang Kubicki. Jedenfalls auf keinen Fall mit jemanden wie Marie-Argne Strack Zimmermann. Und das wollen wir uns ein bisschen klar machen. Nämlich in der Kommunikation von Wolfgang Kubicki. Er ist also nach diesem doch sehr nervenaufreibenden Parteitag angetreten, um den Tagesthemen auch noch ein Interview zu geben. Er ist zugeschaltet.
Muss man dazu sagen, dass es sehr heiß war. Ich kenne einen Clip, den nur der Koch gemacht hat.
Ja.
Es war ja ein sehr heißer langer Tag für den alten Mann.
Ja. Ja, man schwitzt ein bisschen und ist auch sonst vielleicht schon etwas derangiert. Kann alles sein. Jesse Wellmer interviewt Wolfgang Kubicki.
Das Ergebnis, heute gerundet so 60 zu 40, äußerst knapp für Sie. Braucht man, um eine Partei zu retten? Nicht eine Partei, die etwas mehr hinter einem steht?
60, 40 ist doch ein gutes Ergebnis. Und ich hatte nicht das Gefühl heute im Parteitag, dass die Partei nicht hinter mir steht. Darum geht es gar nicht. Die Freien Demokraten sind ein lustiges Völkchen. Streitbar, selbstbewusst und auch professionell genug, mit solchen Situationen umgehen zu können. Wettbewerb schadet der Partei nicht, sondern stärkt die Partei.
So, genau mal gegen diesen üblichen Konsens. Ja, wir müssen jetzt sehen, dass wir alle in einem Boot sitzen. Wir müssen alle einen. Wir wollen keine Konflikte. Nein, der Konflikt ist in der Partei. Wettbewerb, das ist doch eh so ein FDP-Ding. Das machen wir jetzt hier. Egal. Find ich genau die richtige Ansage. Also das muss man jetzt von links lernen. Ja, also das ist jetzt zuhören und für die eigene Sache.
Angenommen, das wäre jetzt erfolgreich gewesen für Arkenstrakts Zimmermann. Hätten wir dann Wolfgang Kubicki auch so reden gehört?
Natürlich nicht. Ja, das ist ja vollkommen klar. Nur, dass man jetzt nicht sagt, ja, wir müssen jetzt...
Das wollte ich nur aus dir herauskitzeln.
Jeder SPD-Politiker, der diese Frage gestellt bekommen hätte nach einem solchen Wahlergebnis, der hätte jetzt gesagt, ja, und ich will mich auch am nächsten Morgen mit der anderen Seite zusammensetzen, denn am Ende geht es ja um unser Land und wir müssen gemeinsam bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Und genau jeder Grüne hätte das so gesagt. Ich höre schon so einen Horbeckton, wie er uns erzählt. Nein, es ist genau die richtige Haltung, die dann noch verstärkt wird. Wirklich, Sternstunde Wolfgang Kubicki.
Ja, also der Applaus für Marie-Agnestrak Zimmermann und ihre Rede hat schon verdeutlicht, dass da auch möglicherweise Lager sind in der Partei. Sie polarisieren ja außerhalb der FDP, aber wie viele zumindest den Eindruck gewinnen konnten, auch innerhalb der FDP. Wie wollen sie denn Marie-Agnestrak Zimmermann und ihre 40% Anhängerschaft noch mehr für sich gewinnen?
Gar nicht, weil...
Gar nicht. Das ist meine Ansage.
Ich bin mal weiter.
Interessiert mich nicht. Also wir hören noch mal....
Zimmermann und ihre 40% Anhängerschaft noch mehr für sich gewinnen.
Gar nicht, weil meine Aufgabe nicht darin besteht, irgendjemand zu gewinnen, sondern dazu beizutragen, dass die Freien Demokraten von den Wählerinnen und Wählern wieder ernst genommen werden. Es ist völlig egal, wie wir uns nach ihnen selbst empfinden, ob wir lustig oder traurig sind. Entscheidend ist, wir brauchen gute Ergebnisse bei Wahlen. Darum werde ich mich kümmern.
Also, Wolfgang Kubicki weiß, dass diese Parteien, gerade so klein wie die FDP und so, mittlerweile medial nur noch reduziert werden auf ihren Chef. Das gilt insbesondere für die FDP nach Christian Lindner. Dass er jetzt sagt, ich möchte diese Partei nach außen wenden, in der Gesellschaft wieder eine Rolle spielen, was aber bedeutet, die Partei bin ich, ist auf jeden Fall nicht ein zu unterstützender Satz im Verhältnis zu dem davor, wo es einfach heißt, naja, es gibt halt, deswegen macht man ja eine Wahl, mehrere Kandidaten und am Ende 50 plus.
Die Überlegung muss doch folgende sein. Wer überhaupt ist noch fähig und willens, die FDP zu wählen? Wenn man die Marie-Agnestrak-Zimmermann-Position haben möchte, dann gibt es dafür ein Angebot, das liegt bei den Grünen oder zum Teilen bei der CDU. Wenn man diesen Essay, den wir dich heute vorstellen, von Franziska Brandner über Liberalismus diest, dann würde ich sagen, zu 99 Prozent wird Marie-Agnestrak-Zimmermann das genauso sehen. Wenn die FDP sich in eine grüne Partei verwandeln will, also in die grüne Realus, dann braucht es die FDP ja gar nicht. Es gibt ja schon ein Angebot, nämlich die Grünen. Dass Marie-Agnestrak-Zimmermann jetzt so beliebt ist in der eigenen Partei, beziehungsweise dass man sagte wohl, ich will den Kubicki nicht, deswegen wähle ich jetzt mal sie, um den Kubicki eins auszuwischen, heißt ja überhaupt nichts über die Beliebtheit von Strack-Zimmermann in der Bevölkerung. Also wenn irgendjemand die FDP so mehr als 5 Prozent bringen kann, dann ist das ein Typ wie Kubicki oder Kubicki selbst. Aber das ist garantiert nicht ein Strack-Zimmermann. Und das ist ja genau das Problem, was wir bei allen Parteien jetzt aus der Mitte vorfinden. Du hast es ja gerade angesprochen, Baerbock nicht beliebt, trotzdem bekommt sie die Posten. Wir sehen das bei der SPD. Also du glaubst doch nicht, dass irgendjemand, wenn man einfach so frei wählen würde, auf die Idee gekommen wäre, Lars Klingweil als Vorsitzenden zu nehmen. Da würden einem ja 100 andere Namen einfallen. Man würde auch bei der CDU, würde man nicht sagen, Friedrich Merz, der gefällt mir so gut. Da würden andere Kandidaten anstehen. Und genau deshalb ist es die richtige Haltung von Kubicki zu sagen, ja gut, das mag ja sein, dass die das in der Partei so sehen. Das ist eben die Berliner Plaza, also parteiinternen Kram. Das hat aber nichts mit dem da draußen zu tun. Und das ist in meinen Augen ein wirkliches Verständnis von populistischer Politik, die ich inhaltlich, um das nochmal zu sagen, vollkommen ablehne.
Ich mache jetzt einen Verweis auf später. Denn wenn wir nachher gegenmacht von Arne Lesen, kommen wir an einigen Stellen drauf zurück, um zu sagen, klar, die FDP verhält sich jetzt so und so. Und im Verhältnis oder im Unterschied dazu macht die SPD, die CDU und so Folgendes. Ich sage jetzt, in dieser Demokratie, über die ich mich eben schon gewundert habe, sind alle Parteien kaputt. Und Arne beschreibt Situationen, in denen man überhaupt nur an Aufbruch und etwas Neues denkt, wenn man den Laden intern auf eine Basis gestellt hat, dass es sich überhaupt lohnt, das zu expandieren. Wir beschreiben aber jetzt schon ganz zynisch und völlig zurecht diese Parteien als completo verloren.
Ja, das ist eine zynische Analyse von mir.
Also dass die Aussage einfach lautet, damit Kubicki gesellschaftlich für die FDP überhaupt noch eine Rolle spielen kann, muss er im Grunde die ganze Partei als Müllhaufen hinter sich lassen und am besten schon mal einen Container werfen. Das sagt wirklich einiges über unseren aktuellen Zustand der Politik.
Das sagt sehr viel aus. Und dennoch ist es, glaube ich, so interessant, dass wir es hier einmal erleben, auch in der Art, wie mit den Journalisten gesprochen wird. Denn Velma fragt jetzt zur AfD. Ich halte diese Position von Kubicki auch für falsch, in Bezug zur Brandmauer oder so. Aber auch die Kommunikation, die einfach jetzt von Kubicki zurückkommt, finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, weil alle sofort sonst, wenn sie irgendwas gefragt werden in dieser Hinsicht oder in anderer, ja, wollen sie dann wirklich enteignen? Oder sehen sie dann nicht, dass diese Gaza-Position schwierig ist? Dann sind alle sofort wieder, ah ja, da muss ich zurück, oder nicht, dass irgendwas nachher in der Bildzeitung oder so steht. Da muss ja, die Linke hat ja auch inzwischen eine solche Angst, Interviews zu geben, dass man auch nur noch beschwichtigend ist. Nee, Kubicki nicht.
Es gibt ja durchaus Punkte, über die auch relativ hart diskutiert wird. Wenn man Marie-Agnieszak Zimmermann heute zugehört hat, dann ist es auch die Brandmauer-Debatte. Das wurde heute deutlich. Sie halten die Debatte für Grund falsch. Und dabei bleiben sie auch, obwohl das viele in der FDP möglicherweise anders sehen?
Ich sehe nicht, dass es viele in der FDP anders sehen. Brandmauer sind für Liberale kein Kriterium. Wir weichen keine Diskussionen aus und wir haben einstehende Überlegungen, die wir präsentieren. Es ist völlig egal, ob CDU zustimmen oder SPD zustimmen oder was auch immer. Was wären wir für eine Partei, wenn wir unsere Überzeugungen und unsere Äußerungen davon abhängig machen würden, wer sonst noch im politischen Spektrum begeistert oder bin ich begeistert ist. Man kann sich darauf verlassen, die Freien Demokraten sind der größte Antipode der AfD. Ich hasse es langsam, dass kein Interview stattfindet, ohne dass mit der AfD geredet wird. Wir machen sich alle größer als sie wirklich ist. Sie ist nicht das Zentrum des Universums.
Auch einfach mal zu artikulieren, ich will jetzt mal keine Frage zur AfD, ist gar nicht so schlecht. Jetzt wirklich diese völlig Egalhaltung.
Für die FDP geht es darum, eine politische Marktlücke zu besetzen, einen Markenkern zu definieren. Wie groß ist das Risiko, dass der vor allem aus ihren rustikalen Sprüchen besteht?
Ja, es kann bewerten, wer weh. Tagesthemen, genauso wie Tagesschau oder was auch immer entscheidend ist, ob wir die Menschen erreichen in diesem Land. Und da traue ich der Partei sehr viel zu. Alles weitere werden wir sehen.
Ja, also.
Das ist doch die richtige Kommunikation. Das ist doch, verschrecken Sie mit Ihrer Politik gegen die Vermieter nicht die Mitte der Bevölkerung. Das ist so eine typische Frage, die jetzt Heidi Reichnecke gestellt bekommt. Dann wird sie versuchen, zu beschwichtigen. Dann ist mir egal, was die Tagesthemen denken, machen wir jetzt einfach so.
Also zur Brandmauer, die FDP hat ja die Brandmauer eingerissen. Auch hier wieder Arne Semmsrott, der das Buch beginnt mit viel schlimmer als wenn die AfD AfD Politik macht, ist wenn die Parteien der angeblich Mitte AfD Politik machen. Die FDP ist also da viel schlimmer als die AfD.
Ich stimme Semmsrott ja da auch völlig zu. Mir geht es ja auch nicht, das inhaltlich gut zu finden.
Zweitens zu diesem alles egal und so weiter. Also wir dürfen nicht übersehen, Kubicki kann es ja, also du betont jetzt, ihm ist das alles egal und das stimmt. Nur er ist halt jetzt die One-Man-Show FDP. Es gibt hinter Kubicki keine FDP. Wir werden niemanden sehen. Niemanden.
Das wird sich zeigen, ob sich da dann andere herausbilden.
Ja, also wird sich zeigen, aber ich kann eine Prognose abgeben.
Bei der SPD wäre, also nehmen wir mal die SPD, die ja in einer ähnlich tiefen Krise steckt. Wenn wir jetzt die SPD nehmen und wissen, was jetzt passieren wird, also nehmen wir mal an, Lars Klingbeil geht, aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Dann wissen wir, dann kommt als nächstes jemand, der Klüssendorf ist und fast genauso ist wie Lars Klingbeil.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, aber das passiert ja jetzt zumindest in den letzten 15 Jahren. SPD immer, einmal kurz Martin Schulz. Dann hat man gemerkt, Martin Schulz, bitte gar keine inhaltlichen Positionen, denn wir wollen einfach nur einen Hype. Und dann stellt sich heraus, dass so ohne Inhalt geht nicht. Das heißt, die SPD hat ja jetzt immer auf Köpfe gesetzt, die alles nur schlimmer gemacht haben, weil sie nur Seeheimer Kreis, Pragmatiker und irgendwas und auf keinen Fall jetzt jemand wie Kevin Kühnert, der eins von Sozialismus sprach, wurde dann auch zu dem angepasstesten Politiker der Welt. Das heißt, das ist ja alles immer total gescheitert, weil man immer sagt, wir müssen alle einigen. Ich muss auch danach noch zum Spargelessen mit dem und dem gehen. Und einfach zu sagen, nee, wir haben jetzt bei der SPD aus der Mitte heraus irgendeine Figur, die polarisiert und die schert sich jetzt nicht darum, ob der Seeheimer Kreis gerne noch 5.000 Panzer nach Israel schicken will. Es ist egal, machen wir nicht. Das wäre genau die richtige Position zu sagen, wir drehen jetzt frei, das ist die einzige Chance überhaupt noch. Und das nimmt man aber nicht im Kaufen. Da verwaltet man den Abstieg immer ganz staatstragend und langweilig.
Auch hier wieder ein kurzer Verweis auf Arne Semshorn. Man hüte sich in diesen Zeiten jetzt vor Kontinuitätsunterstellung, denn nichts läuft gerade kontinuierlich weiter, außer zwei Sachen, das Fernsehprogramm und wie die SPD ihre Leute rekrutiert. Nur ich sehe da auch, Lars Klingball ist der Letzte. Also da ist einfach niemand anderes mehr, der diese Linie so fortführt.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
In der SPD hassen alle Lars Klingball.
Jaja, aber ich kann ja über ganz viele Vorsitzende, die die SPD schon hatte, sagen, dass die nicht beliebt waren. Und trotzdem hat man es immer weitergeführt.
Und deswegen sage ich ja jetzt keine Kontinuitätsformatungen.
Natürlich ist die Performance von Kubicki nicht immer einwandfrei, aber vielleicht authentisch. Jetzt kommt der Clip, den du kennst und den müssen wir natürlich spielen. Also abschließende Frage, wie bringt man jetzt die FDP nach vorne? Mit einer, glaube ich, mit einer kleinen Sprache vielleicht, oder?
Wie soll der gelingen? Wie sieht die Marktlücke konkret aus? Wie definieren Sie sie, in die Sie rein wollen, mit der Sie erfolgreich sein wollen? Welches Konzept?
Ja, also wir müssen einfach nur eine klare Position beziehen und eine klare Sprache sprechen, anders als in der Vergangenheit. Wir sind ja von vielen Menschen gar nicht mehr identifiziert worden. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass bis vor fünf Wochen die Freien Demokraten bei den meisten Meinungsumfragen gar nicht mehr ausgewiesen worden sind, weil noch unser Sonstiges abgestattet worden sind.
Einfach klare Sprache. Ja, sehr zum Wohle.
Das könnte man zum Einbürgerungstest.
Ob man das nachsprechen kann oder verstehen kann.
Ob man das aufschreiben kann. Wer das transkribieren kann, sofort einbürgern. Also ich sehe hier wirklich Hoffnungslosigkeit.
Aber wenigstens wird es lustig.
Deutschland ist wirklich das allerletzte Land. Schauen wir mal nach England. Die BBC hat jetzt eine ganze Newsnight-Sendung, also eine komplette Sendung, sich selbst zensiert, weil sie in irgendeinem Halbsatz Farage falsch zitiert haben. So mächtig ist der mittlerweile mit seinem Reformding. So, der Typ hat vor zehn Jahren Brexit verbrockt. Dann hat er dazu geführt, oder die immer wieder provoziert, dass sich das keiner eingesteht. So, man hat also ganz viele Ausreden mit, ja, da war halt Corona und dann war halt Ukrainekrieg und was auch immer. Und dass man sich das wirklich selber herbeizugefügt hat, dass einfach ein Drittel des Landes komplett in die absolute Armut gerutscht sind. Wartelisten bei NHS, sieben Monate und dann ganz scheiße. Also Parteiensystem einmal komplett, Tories gibt es gar nicht mehr, Labour sehen wir ja, was da los ist und so. Selbst Tony Blair sagt es irgendwie, es geht so nicht weiter. Und die einzige Hoffnung ist, Reform irgendwie mit Verarsch, der soll jetzt nächster Ministerpräsident werden. So, Frankreich. Also Macron war derjenige, der eine neue Partei erfunden hat. Und schon wieder abgemeldet. Ja. So, dass in Deutschland überhaupt noch FDP, die haben wir nicht vor 15 Jahren aussortiert. Also die sind schon mal rausgeflogen, haben wir die wieder zugelassen. Was ist denn das für ein Quatscher? Ja. CDU. Also ihr habt noch christlich-konservative Parteien, von denen wir jetzt durch die Entzüglichkeit gesehen haben, wie christlich die sind.
Gar nicht.
Es ist wirklich grotesk. Ja. So, dass wir überhaupt es so weit geschafft haben.
Das ist erstaunlich.
Dass in der Frankfurt Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung 25 Jahre auf den Gründungsmoment 2001 zurückgeblickt werden kann. Und man feststellt, wow, also Jörg Thoma hat noch mal die erste Ausgabe der Sonntagszeitung gelesen und hat sich gefragt, welche Welt ist das? Hier ist ja nichts wie 2001, außer die Tagesthemen.
Ja.
So, dass wir noch Tagesthemen haben und Kubicki da noch in dem, so haben wir es seit 50 Jahren gemacht, Gesprächen zugeschaltet ist, um als 74-Jähriger noch mal die Hoffnung der Partei zu beschreiben.
Und auch dem Wein noch zuspricht, ganz wie früher, der alten Bundesrepublik.
Das ist einfach groteske Welt, in der wir hier leben.
Es ist grotesk, ja.
Es ist unglaublich.
Das heißt, mit diesem kleinen Anlauf gehen wir in den Salon, sprechen wie gesagt über Gegenmacht von Arne Semmsrott. Ich will dich auch fragen, was traust du eigentlich der Zivilgesellschaft zu? Ich hier vielleicht doch ein bisschen weniger als Arne Semmsrott. Darüber müssen wir diskutieren. Wir sprechen über die öffentliche Kunstfreiheit von Christoph Möllers und Nils Weinberg. Die Frage also, kann der Staat eingreifen, wenn er zum Beispiel meint, dass ein Kunstwerk antisemitisch ist? Wie ist das überhaupt? Wie frei ist die Kunst, wenn sie staatlich gefördert ist? Weiter dann ein Roman, der wirklich unglaublich beeindruckend ist, der so minimalistisch ist und eine so interessante, sehr einsame Figur. Er ist 400 Seiten lang, aber trotzdem ist er sehr, sehr sparsam mit den Worten. So ist es auch gesetzt, sehr sparsam in den Dialogen. Literarische Essays von Judith Schalansky, dann Musik. Und wir gucken uns mal an, wie jetzt eigentlich Franziska Brandner so dieses Strackzimmermannlager für sich gewinnen will. Und was heißt das eigentlich für die Grünen?
Politiker, die Laufkundschaft einfangen wollen, ne? Ja. Also, Gegenmacht von Arne Semsrott wird gleich ein großer Kontrapunkt sein. Zum Thema Menschenfischerei.
Wir sprechen über all das im Salon. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr den Salon abonniert und auf diese Weise auch den Podcast unterstützt. Möglich ist das mit einem Klick bei Apple oder mit einem Patreon-Account. Wir empfehlen allerdings Steady. Dort findet man alles am besten und am übersichtlichsten. Am besten geht man auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de. Dort ist ein goldener Button, der führt zum Salon. Dann kann man sich anmelden und ganz wichtig, man kann den Salon dann so hören, wie man möchte. Man ist nicht an irgendetwas gebunden, sondern kann sich den RSS-Feed überall einfügen, wo man ihn gerne hätte. Dann auf in den Salon.
Bis gleich.